Hello everyone, and
welcome to the content
video for machine learning
sentiment analysis example.
OK, so sentiment analysis
is another problem
that machine learning models
have done extremely well with.
And the idea is
basically you take data
and you try and determine
or predict the sentiment,
meaning if someone is very
angry or if someone's very
happy or very
positive or neutral
machine learning can determine
that their sentiment in the data
itself.
So we've got some data set
from Amazon, IMDb and Yelp,
and then we're going to take
a look at how models rate
the sentiment and then
compare the output
from the different models.
I should also mention there's
a programming activity in here,
so I'm going to cover how
it's done with one model
and then the programming
activity will actually
be to then do-it-yourself.
So to build multiple
models, fit the data
and then predict the sentiment
on those multiple models.
That's the programming activity.
But let's get started
with the first model.
OK, so here we have
sentiment example.py.
And let's take a
look at the data.
The data that will
probably be helpful.
So here are some Amazon reviews.
And then this is training data.
So it's got a numeric value for
the sentiment of this review.
And then the same
is true for IMDb,
and then the same is true for
Yelp, essentially a review
with a score on whether or
not it's positive or negative.
So then how the heck do we
build a model to predict that?
Well, again, it's loading
the data, fits the data,
predict the data.
It's actually pretty simple.
But the time and
the code is spent
with the data preprocessing,
transformations,
different things like that.
A lot of time in data analytics
is spent on the data itself,
which kind of makes sense.
OK, so here we go.
So we have our Amazon data,
Yelp data, and our IMDb data.
I have all of those files.
So I load the files.
I'm going to read them
into a CSV with Pandas.
Pandas library, the functions
are so great and easy to use.
So read CSV, puts it
into a Pandas data frame,
which is essentially an
in-memory spreadsheet.
And then I can concatenate them
all using the concat method.
So now I've got all of my
data loaded into a data frame,
kind of like a spreadsheet, and
all of it's now in one place
that I can look at.
OK, now I'm going to
transform the data little bit
so I don't have to fit
on uppercase, lowercase,
different punctuation or
versions of the words.
This kind of just preprocesses
all of the data to get it
lowercase and less
amount-- the words
turn into-- think
of them like tokens.
So the more I can get
the words themselves
into a uniform format,
the less tokens there are,
and then the more accurate
my fitting can be.
OK, so I preprocessed the data.
And then here is where
the learning happens.
Remember, it's all
here in the fitting.
So this is where the learning
happens of, here's the data.
Under what circumstances
do these words
have a positive or a
negative sentiment?
That learning is
done in the fitting.
Then I transform the X's.
Remember, the X's
are the inputs.
And then the Y's are the output.
X's are the
independent variables.
Y is the dependent
variable, remember,
in an independent input.
So those are my X's
that I'm inputting.
And then I make my
predictions on them.
And the predictions
are done in a test set
where I can actually gauge,
were they correct or not?
How accurate is this model?
And then I can print that out.
So let me give that
a run right there.
OK, so on our first model--
take a sec.
It's still fitting.
That's normal.
Actually, the
longest will probably
be, for your
programming activity--
if you check down here is MLP.
That's a neural network,
a simple neural network.
But that one will
take the longest.
OK, so our first one is done.
And our accuracy is 80%.
You can see in my output where
I'm highlighting right here.
Model accuracy is 80%,
which is pretty good.
So this model--
that's the accuracy.
So now here's the
programming activity
that I'd like you to do.
I created for you all
of these models now.
Let me expand that right there.
So now you've got an additional
six machine learning models
that I'd like you
to fit the data
and then make the predictions.
And here's the setup right here.
Here's the y data right here.
You need to fit the
classifier, transform the X
so you can do predictions,
make the predictions,
calculate the accuracy by
calling accuracy_score, and then
printing the model
and the accuracy.
And that's it.
The code of the model itself
is not really complicated.
You can see a lot of
time in the program
is spent getting the data in the
right format or the best format
that you can learn from it
and then make predictions.
That's really a lot of your
time as a data analyst and data
scientist is dealing
with the data.
And with your knowledge of how
machine learning models work
and knowing what the
format the data needs
to be in so that
something can be learned,
all that information
is in your head
on how the data needs
to be formatted and fit
into a machine learning model.
That's where a lot of
your time will be spent.
Once the data is
all ready to go,
then you can just crank
through the models
like you're going to do in
your programming activity.
I should also mention
the solution is
in sentiment_example_solution.
But I highly recommend
that you do not just
go to the solution, read
through it, think, OK.
Yeah, I got this.
No problem.
Do it with your own two
hands, go through it.
The little issues
you might run along--
figure them out and fix them.
That's the really the value,
the aha moment of, yes, I
can do this.
I can figure this out.
So all right, so give that a
try, that programming activity.
And this concludes our content
video of Machine Learning--
Sentiment Analysis Example.
Thanks for watching.